how's it going bros my name is Pippa
today were playing best edge I'm Swedish
I know how it's pronounced alright the
game got updated and it has this whole
new area called tool bin which in
Swedish means a big fat giant canoe I
don't I didn't want to say caught anyway
but this game is [ __ ] awesome I love
this game I'm excited to wreak some more
[ __ ] with besa besa besa besa
I don't think we still have her though
no we don't we're gonna have to build a
new best of the Beast Earl Abra's all
right we need to build a catapult let's
see if I remember how to do that
miss enemy's bets enemies all right
let's try it what better to be Wow you
kill like three of them this is the
matrix there's no limitations come on we
got a thing better than a [ __ ]
catapult okay this is gonna fly
watch watch it look at it
it's the Beast passerbys they see the
Beast
we see the bees everybody face see the
Beast they see twist spinning block of
flame throw damn it
spinning flamethrower Wow good job se
pissing to be special beast why have one
flamethrower when you can have Oh a lot
of flamethrowers hey no busy burned base
see that big okay now basic and steer
how dare you challenge let's see the
Beast Shh No Bessie no [ __ ]
slaughterhouse we miss one come on man
all right busy flame on baby son of a
[ __ ] don't worry bros I know what I'm
doing
I know science [ __ ] up back up but
there's nothing you did nothing Bessie
you dishonor your farmer and better how
do we kill those in those [ __ ] towers
you know what [ __ ] the catapult idea you
know what I'm gonna do this
Swedish style Bessy that be this is so
[ __ ] genius
why does [ __ ] the government not
invent me to become a spy I mean to make
these deaf stuff for people
[ __ ] help that was not part of the
plan Bessy could not handle the Beast
ruff yes ha ha ha ah [ __ ] hell what
was the problem in this design I don't
understand alright maybe maybe that was
a terrible idea
maybe what a great design who came up
with this Bessie the Beast has conquered
a lot of [ __ ] and a lot of ass that's
right I kill your cows blue yes we got
them yes [ __ ] keep spinning like busy
but ain't no [ __ ] spin like Bessie
Wow
one more baby no ok we can still do it
we can still do it
Bessie never gives up Bessie probably
should give up no never never
yes yes we got him Oh God it broke a
[ __ ] broke Bessie's ass is broken I
repeat Betsy's a s is broken
does that mean we give up yes
no it does not no it does [ __ ] not
mean we give up did pit if I give up
YouTube when it's ass broke its ass has
never been broken but debtor's I did
break my ass once Prez
true story I'll tell you about it one
time you do not get a bandage on your
ass though which made me very
disappointed when I reach the hospital
but a broken ass does not mean a broken
man am i right Missy how could you
possibly understand you're a catapult
flame on bitch-ass flame [ __ ] on are
you [ __ ] my anus out that little
[ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ] come here you
come here let me [ __ ] you are you
[ __ ] kidding me
alright then let's just do this again
[ __ ] broke my ass for you man alright
this is [ __ ] it we did it we did it
know who's left yes
oh sweet [ __ ] victory are fibrous
what what is this kill the flock kill
the flock they said oh it done better
the bees percent apiece you know
Leonardo da Vinci was my grandfather so
I know a thing or two about building
[ __ ] all right
this gonna be good baby look at that
spin look at you
facilities best enemies recipes burn
them all Missy abandon my stupid birds
think you can find [ __ ] [ __ ] you oh oh
[ __ ] I just realized I just realized I
just realized a wastewater design
alright now we got it this is it presses
ass is broken but busy it's a fighter
bases party man he was
oh god that just kills him [ __ ]
hitting them with my schatz wanted to
tell me alright here we go
this should be good go back no one is
saying I really get the [ __ ] best
ideas at this time I mean look at this
[ __ ] oh my [ __ ] god
I'm a [ __ ] genius oh god this is
getting out of control
calm down Missy stop - head back better
alright if s it wasn't a [ __ ] killing
machine before she sure as hell is now I
don't know what that smoke is coming
from but
okay this doesn't do it I'm out of
[ __ ] ideas so close
Bessie I have one more [ __ ] idea and
I feel like it's stupid enough that it
might actually work
she's flying just as planned
ha ha ha ha ha ha okay this is stupid
enough that it might actually work
[ __ ] you Bessie I new plan
that's a [ __ ] Albus we're gonna do
ders
okay here we go here we go this is
[ __ ] it
yes sir
fist me daddy chef Elise action focus
this toward lilt you think I can't fly
[ __ ] plus I invented the goddamn it
goddamn it basically going down so this
is a flying man
very interesting oh [ __ ]
okay so it's the balloons we need to
destroy got it Bessie the base it looks
like we actually need to build something
that can [ __ ] fly so this game is
[ __ ] insane man insane man that
membrane I'm not doing too well am i all
right flight a but a balloon has to be
good right penis penis penis penis penis
okay this thing flies and turns I'll
take it I'll [ __ ] take it
haha this is why I dropped out of
college
[ __ ] yeah okay okay yes it might not be
the best about AWACS pop that balloon
like it's a [ __ ] set come on
but set a bird alright Bessie does not
steer very well I don't think Bessie
steers at all to be honest I think it's
more of a look this is why NASA I should
hire me right [ __ ] here look at this
[ __ ]
come on come on [ __ ] that ballon [ __ ] it
oh [ __ ] da [ __ ] no I worked too hard for
this that's right pissy all right next
one
but see the [ __ ] [ __ ]
all this game is so satisfying Oh
[ __ ] paid my pants
what is this place it appease miss
enemies base enemies goes to space
sunburn but I Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam oh god
they attack okay they attack
all those mother sly [ __ ]
alright the windmill of death what you
gonna do though why he can't kill me
Kenny ha ha ha yeah
Bessie come on man touch it touch it I
know you want to [ __ ] oh god oh god I
[ __ ] myself that that [ __ ] works
best design 2010 Cinque oh [ __ ] we lost
one it's okay it's okay it's okay don't
panic
Oh God penny panic panic oh god oh god
he's going foot Bessy nah oh right in a
dick God come on man come on you double
dildo [ __ ] ah I love that
Oh wallets oh boy oh I love that is
there anyone else hiding come on I
really want to go to sleep it's [ __ ]
latest [ __ ] no oh god oh god oh god oh
oh oh
just [ __ ] piss ha I spit in my eye
and it burns hello how is that Hey all
right [ __ ]
ah [ __ ] is in my mouth ah like this
video
Oh